können wir vielleicht alle mal aufhören
mit dieser beschissenen Elon Musk
vererehrung ja er hat Kohle knapp 240
Milliarden mehr als die Hälfte vom
Jahreshaushalt der Bundesregierung aber
er gibt's auch nur für Schwachsinn aus
ähnlich wie die Bundesregierung seine
Firma neuralink baut hirnimplantate dann
können wir unsere Gedanken direkt mit
Computern verbinden will ich gar nicht
wenn ich mir vorstelle direkt mit meinem
Schall Windows 11 Rechner verbunden zu
sein möchte ich mich sofort selber
runterfahren und wer bitte kauft Twitter
und warum um es in X umzubenennen die
Plattform bleibt doch dieselbe sinnlose
hassmaschine wo ein usernens Moment Elon
Musk die deutsche Flüchtlingspolitik
kritisiert und wahlaufrufe für die AFD
teilt dir haben sie doch ins Gehirn
getwittert bzw geixt